allein in berlin freunde herzlich
willkommen wir heute mal wieder am
dienstag selbstverständlich seine neuen
episode gaza-stadt mal wieder mit den
besten tipp der woche ja
da hatten wir jetzt aber auch mit den
richtigen täter videos die ich für heute
vorbereitet habe und da bin ich dann
auch schon direkt wieder diese
wundervollen kitzen kommen übrigens am
in den beamer fahrer sehen hier freunde
[Musik]
super weltklasse die hupe weltklasse der
mitarbeiter ja der wohl auch
ruhiggestellt leute ich von mir aus
monster beschluss das heiß machen
demnach nur ist es passiert
nein es war alles aufgeplatzt
ich frag mich
er ist warum ich so etwas vorgeschlagen
krieger und warum ist da noch like und
hier mit rein nehmen wenn ihr was wollt
dann müsst also wenn ich mir was wollt
dann ist es auch recht wollen bruder
goethe ist hier du bist hier goethe
gegen oder bestellt wurde
es war ja bruder du bist die auch foto
schobert angeblich 15 millionen bilder
aber nur 90 favoriten ja ich glaube ich
eigentlich
[Applaus]
13.000
icloud gibt es nicht okay ein schatz du
musst auf irgendwelche sozialen medien
präsent sein
wir müssen uns ausdenken wie der reihe
vor diesem typen dass er immer so sachen
mit angela merkel macht die chance
facebook benutzt du dich mal meine oma
zu erreichen wie es wohl war das so
perfekt passt facebook benutzer nicht
mehr meiner oma ich bin auch bei
instagram zu erreichen
instagram ist gut ja okay wie soll dann
ist sogar man kann aussehen der produkte
gesund ich hätte da wird es ja nicht so
viel geld verdient angela merkel
plötzlich für hey guckt mal aus dem
partner ein neues werbung für domino
amazon jim apropos ich hab' ich habe
keinen einzigen teebeutel meiner wohnung
wollen
angie will bilder im parkhaus machen
hast du deine schönen geschmacklos
pausen versuche einfach mal lächeln mal
nicht so aufgesetzt kommen
so wird das nix
ja
einzige was ich jetzt noch gern sehen
würde wer angela merkel auf twitter wie
sie renegade tanz
[Musik]
leider sieht der hund nach dem aufstand
immer noch besser aus als ich 30 stunden
geschlafen
sie glaubt hässlichkeit meine damen und
herren einen schönen guten tag liebe
schülerinnen und schüler und diverse ich
heisse euch willkommen zum neuen
schuljahr
ich gehe mit euch einmal die
anwesenheitsliste durch und falls ihr
euren namen wird hier sollen
und dann hab ich hab hier die cantina
quarantine
was kommt als nächstes
wird dann mit afrobeat ja da
wir haben aber sonst noch so einer
klasse sitzen carola carola klar man
kennt sie und die conova mit cq nora mit
zehn natürlich auch eine start bruder
sitzt auch noch toilettenpapier
dann habe ich hier ich schaue mir das
nicht vorher nicht derart auf alle
wirklich hervorragend mit der
zauberflöte
ich weiß auch das wesen wird mir meine
mutter und ich dachte ich habe meinen
kam hier liegen lassen
[Musik]
bei arten von dino
der normale kino kino der passive die
note
[Musik]
ich schwöre pizza sohn oder ich glaube
eher als pizza sohn 1 ja er heisst pizza
soll ein softtop folgt ihm mal lasst ihr
lieben gruß da ich finde die videos so
lutz tja die die ja in der
öffentlichkeit macht richtig richtig
geil hallo ein freund von mir kann mit
seiner neuen rat einen voll guten
immobilien und er kann schon richtig
weit und den schon zum zuschauen
gekommen
das schicke ich auch vorne und hinten
nicht warum sagen leute zu beginn ihres
gigs videos hat es macht doch keinen
sinn als ob ich mir dann denke ich okay
wenn du das sagst dann sollte ich jetzt
nicht weiter
er gibt uns jetzt gründe warum er ein
schlechter freund ist
[Musik]
deine lippen sind zu groß
lästig
das ist jetzt nicht real talk affe der
da gerade kocht
[Musik]
der krieg sei perfekt auf zurück
ja wahrscheinlich dritter ist jetzt auch
noch um
[Musik]
ja
klasse von hutchison mougnina tiefer
setzen so sie war die kopie hop maji
maji maji pippa lee
englisch buch auf wunsch
wissen stellt das video heute ist voll
von ca
[Musik]
jetzt hat auch früher sein können ich
weiß gar nicht warum aber warum war man
als kind immer so voll besetzen von von
dreck und schlamm und und so von weg
ohne neue socken anziehen und nähe und
machen oder war nicht so
krankes opfer als kind hier in diesem
teaser-video bereits lesen konntet
möchte die person dass man in der
kommentar sektion mal so tut als würde
man einen kommentar von einer 40
jährigen mutter auf facebook schreiben
und wir gucken uns jetzt mal ein paar
kommentare darunter an auch susi was
machst du denn da das schaut ja witzig
aus liebe grüße sabrina rusche agathe
wir müssen unbedingt mal wieder ein
sektchen trinken und wie groß die mäuse
schon geworden sind liebe grüße sibylle
8 uhr so leider werde ich ja ganz
neidisch ich hoffe ihr genießt die
schönen sonnigen tage berechtigt hat mir
auch ein bisschen sonne mit ganz liebe
grüße oder ich habe neulich das
spielchen candy crush runtergeladen kann
es nur empfehlen liebe grüße annemarie
hatte wie geht es dir meine tastatur als
kaputt und wie kann man erkennt werden
sie nicht reparieren ich hoffe ihr seid
gesund li begrüßte sabine mensch freut
mich dass sie gut im spanien urlaub
angekommen seid super fotos liebe grüße
an die kids bis ganz bald liebe grüße
olga susi das ist ja ein schöner beitrag
schaut witzig aus wünsche dir und den
kids noch einen schönen nachmittag liebe
grüße ihr maranow susanne ich habe noch
eins dieser witzigen kleinen million
bilder gefunden ich hoffe es gefällt dir
liebe grüße ute ist bei euch der
osterhase auch gekommen meiner kleinen
hat er etwas schockierend ein bilderbuch
mitgebracht have tax day home dann noch
meine lieben wir verbringen unsere
hashtag wochenende in hashtag quarantäne
aber der hashtag osterhase trotzdem
vorbeigekommen liebe grüße bleibt gesund
und das gibt mir so den rest wir werden
das jetzt für heute an der stelle möchte
heutige wieso nötig sagt hughes
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde werden solch gefallen hat dann
lass gern einen daumen hoch unter dem
video hier da schreibt man bei euren job
namen und in die kommentare und folgt
auf mir dort ist der laser luca habt ihr
schon beginn des videos gesehen der
beste ticket der woche kommt ja jede
woche von mir angeliefert wahnsinn
allerdings befinden wir uns jetzt auch
schon im auto meine lieben freunde
findet hier oben ein smiley angewendet
werden da draufsteht könnte meinen kanal
kostenlos abonnieren dann verpasst ihr
keine videos mehr wenn ihr allerdings
schon ab und steht dennoch die glocke
denn dann bekommt eine benachrichtigung
sobald ich was neues video soll
genau und hier ist ein video auf dem
zweit kanal auch echt würde ich nicht
drauf klicken damit
[Musik]